it sounds more California than Cornwall
but new key is about to enter the space
race
parked up at the airport is Cosmic girl
a jumbo that in a previous life flew two
and a half million people now it's the
launch pad for a 21 meter rocket that
will be released over the Atlantic just
minutes later its cargo of nine
satellites will be in orbit
is on to launch or air launch means that
we can use an airport we're not having
to build a launch pad in the middle of
you know some really remote location
this Airport's really good at landing
and taking off 747s you know and that's
what this is it just has a really cool
rocket under its wing this time
after taking off from new key Cosmic
girl will head to the Drop Zone off
Island South Coast she'll do laps around
What's called the racetrack while
Engineers carry out final checks then at
35 000 feet the rocket will release via
its engines and accelerate to 8 000
miles an hour past Portugal and into
space
in the cockpit will be Squadron leader
Matthew stanard he normally flies
typhoon jet fighters for the RAF but
launching the first satellites into
space from UK soil takes some beating
it's an incredible sight to watch it go
you know it starts off level with you
and just out the window here is you
literally it's framed by the rocket as
she goes
um and just watching her go to space and
you can just keep watching it going and
going and going and I remember on the
first one Mission Control called that
she was going through 150 000 feet and
it was as bright as the sun still going
to space
virgin orbit has successfully launched
satellites on four Rockets from its
California base but that followed a test
flight that failed and the UK's civil
aviation Authority has been cautious in
giving the Spaceport the go-ahead it has
taken months to get the paperwork signed
off the authorities had to check the
blast zone of a fully fueled rocket
blowing up liaise with air traffic
control on clearing the skies and
assessed the risk to shipping if
anything falls from the skies
Britain is already one of the biggest
Builders of satellites but the
government says having the first
Spaceport in Europe could be worth 3.8
billion pounds to the economy over the
next decade opposition on the globe
means we're in a very good position not
so much for those equatorial huge
payload satellites that we grew up as
children seeing but small low earth
observation satellites the com
satellites we're very well positioned we
in Norway have been looking at our
opportunities given our geography and
I'm delighted to say that unlike in the
race the South Pole we look set to beat
the Norwegians on this one
for Cornwall this is huge not just
because it's an inspiration for young
people but because of the good
year-round jobs that will be attracted
to one of the most deprived parts of the
country